[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up broth
good day walter good day how are you
doing
i'm surviving yeah it seems like a long
time that
i saw you lost well yes we do this once
a week don't we
will he open up for us with the word of
prayer i think we will need it
yes our loving heavenly father
we are living in such momentous times
and without you we do not
have a hope but the great hope that we
have
is centered on you and therefore i pray
lord that you will
enlighten us with your spirit and
protect us with your angels in jesus
name
amen amen
so today let's talk about what's
happening in the world again
yes i think it's time that we go there
i think it was necessary that we
give a very clear biblical outline
as to what constitutes babylon
and i think the talks that we had on the
doctrines of the serpent
give us the background so that we know
who is teaching
the serpent theology and who has been
identified in scripture
as the great anti-power
against jesus christ masquerading
as an angel of light yes
apparently for him but negating all of
his teachings
and the plan of salvation
and where are we heading we're heading
for a final conflict
a conflict of such an enormous scale
that the world has never seen anything
like it
yes and the events are happening so
rapidly around us
that once we've got this basis we have
to go back to where we know in the
stream of time and then we can
look again at some of the details and go
back to where are we now in the stream
of time
so yes and this will continue like this
up until the end up until the end so
we must get the message so this that
we're going to be
dealing with today is also linking on to
where you've given
given us a basis to work from with this
doctrine of the serpent but we must
always make sure
that we have the right filters in place
and the filter is the word of god
with the assistance that we have
fortunately of the spirit of prophecy
which has to be in harmony with the word
of god
and when we apply that filter
then we are now then we know that we are
working with the prophetic scenario
and not with wild speculations it's the
filter
that's important correct and then
um also important
is what is uh what is our position
in this whole scenario where do we stand
what do we do
what is our role when do we get involved
yes
when do we stand back and look as
observers
now what does a sower do doesn't he sow
seed
yes and then does he go
and pluck up the plant or does he wait
patiently for the seed
to germinate and to grow so we can do
the sowing
but we cannot do the growing that's
something
that takes a special power that is not
ours to
to give so let's look at some of these
issues
we've titled this one north versus south
but there could be many titles and
subtitles
i'm sure you will think of many yes and
put them in the lengths but
why are we talking about north versus
south
because this is the final battle as
described in the book of daniel
and then we have to apply it to the
times we are living in
so this is actually an ongoing process
every few months you must be able to
give a lecture on daniel
because it changes as we go along not
the information
but the developments yes continue to
change
in jeremiah chapter 6 16 we read
thus says the lord stand ye in the ways
and see and ask for the old paths
where is the good way and walk therein
and you shall find rest for your souls
it's beautiful yes but they said
we will not walk therein said
that is the history of humanity
god gave us the path of salvation
god gave us all the criteria
and he said choose that path it's the
path of life
and humanity says we will not walk
therein
but who is jeremiah talking to here the
church
he's talking to god's people and what do
god's people say
we will not walk therein we will not
walk there in
do you think it's changed and we've
become better or
are we still exactly the same like
solomon said there's nothing new under
the sun
there's nothing new under the sun so
this is a very sad statement
but many will choose
the broad way but thank god
not all
in nine testimonies we read satan is a
diligent bible student so what should we
be
even more diligent bible students yes
he knows that his time is short
and he seeks at every point to counter
work the work of the lord
upon this earth whenever you do
something for god can you expect
opposition
yes 100 it's already a criteria with us
if we don't get it we ask ourselves
what did we do wrong
it is impossible to give any idea of the
experience of the people of god
who shall be alive upon the earth when
the celestial
glory and a repetition of the
persecutions of the past
are blended that's an amazing statement
so what glory will be blended with
persecution cannot be the
persecution cannot be the glory of god
it must be a false one
it must be a false glory that is blended
with persecution and it's a celestial
glory so
so the bible tells us that satan will
deceive the very elect even
fire coming down from heaven and with
this
powerful movement whereby he deceives
humanity
he will link it to persecution
and try and eradicate god's people
from the face of the earth
this is a very fascinating thing and
there will be a terrible experience for
god's people
they will walk in the light proceeding
from the throne of god this is now god's
people
by means of the angels there will be
constant communication between heaven
and earth and
satan surrounded by evil angels and
claiming to be god
will work miracles of all kinds to
deceive if possible the very elect
god's people will not find their safety
in working miracles
why not because satan is doing it yes
yeah how will you distinguish between
the one or between the other
so what is the weapon that god's people
have
the word that word truth it is written
yeah
god's people will not find their safety
in working miracles
for satan will counterfeit the miracles
that will be wrought
god's tried and tested people will find
their power
in the signs spoken of in exodus 31
12 to 18. we'll have to look at that
right
they are to take their stand on the
living word
it is written this is the only
foundation upon which they can stand
securely
so it's very imperative for the devil
to undermine the authority of the word
of god
and we've dealt with that in some of our
discussions
and how important how important it is
that we
stick to what the word says
this is the only foundation upon which
they can stand securely
those who have broken their covenant
with god will in that day
be without god and without hope
and it's important if you take this
whole thing in context
where it begins satan is a diligent
bible student
so the things that he's going to do if
you're not grounded
in the word it's going to look biblical
to you that
the thing is it's going to quote the
bible didn't you come to jesus quoting
the bible
yes but he takes it out of context and
he twists it
so let's look at those verses in exodus
and the lord spake unto moses saying
speak thou also unto the children of
israel saying
verily my sabbaths you shall keep
for it is a sign between me and you
throughout your generations that you may
know that i am the lord that does
sanctify you
so the important point here is that if
you acknowledge the sabbath
you are acknowledging the god that
sanctifies you
so where do you get your salvation from
where do you get your direction
from as to how you should walk from him
from him so not from someone else
not from someone who's following the
doctrines of the serpent
obviously not right so in other words
the sabbath becomes a sign of
acknowledgement
that you accept the authority
and the guidance of
the lord you shall keep the sabbaths
therefore
for it is holy unto you everyone that
defileth it shall surely be put to death
now that was a type right god was
working here as a theocracy
in other words everybody who doesn't
acknowledge that god
is the one who is the one with authority
will eventually suffer the consequence
of separation
by their own refusal yes not because god
is vindictive
every single person that will be lost
will
have only what he has chosen
yes absolutely for ever doeth any work
there in that soul shall be cut off
from amongst his people now what does
that mean
it means being engaged in your own works
to try and save yourself
you have to rest in the completed work
of god
you still had to eat you still had to
take your ox
to the drinking you had to do those
things
six days may work be done but in the
seventh is the sabbath of rest
holy to the lord whosoever do with any
work in the sabbath he shall surely be
put to death
wherefore the children of israel shall
keep the sabbath to observe the sabbath
throughout their generations
for a perpetual covenant so if it is the
sign that god is the one that sanctifies
it
can i remove it no not possible right
it is a sign between me and the children
of israel forever
for in six days the lord made the
heavens the earth
and on the seventh day he rested and was
refreshed and we discussed that
this is a very complicated thing for the
people living in this age of
evolutionary thinking
you have to actually believe what the
word says there yes
that god created it in six days
otherwise the sabbath becomes
meaningless
correct so you're already at loggerheads
with a scientific fraternity
and he gave unto moses when he had made
an end of communing with him upon mount
cyanide two tables of testimony tables
of stone written with the finger of god
how many commandments were on those
tables
ten ten not nine no not seven
not eight ten so
god's people must keep
all ten if you link these bible verses
to the comment ah the statement that we
read earlier
why was this read to show how important
it will be
in the end time deception that the devil
will bring
towards them it must be part of the
deception
i like this statement by martin luther
and it sounds very harsh but in the
light
of what we just discussed in the
previous ones
the doctrine of the serpent
they are actually very powerful
he wrote if you do not contend with your
whole heart against the empire's
government of the pope
you cannot be saved now that sounds very
harsh
because there are many many good
christians in the roman catholic system
people who really love the lord who do
not understand
i mean i was a catholic i didn't
understand the
fullness of their doctrine what it
actually
meant that it was so totally contrary to
the bible
and i believe that there are many within
the church that don't understand that
either
and if they should see it they would be
devastated whoever takes the light in
the religion and worship of popery will
be eternally lost in the world to come
because it is totally contrary to what
the bible teaches right
if you reject it potpourri you must
expect to incur
every kind of danger even to lose your
lives
but it is far better to be exposed to
such perils in this world than to keep
silence
so long as i live i will denounce to my
brethren the saw and plague of babylon
for fear that many who are with us
should
fall back like the rest into the
bottomless pit
that's almost like a prediction and we
discussed that
and we said that if you align yourselves
with babylon which at that stage
martin luther stage was the papacy and
the dragon
but it's almost like a predict
prediction that some will fall back
and join the system again and that's the
sad part
babylon has fallen it was fallen fallen
it fell again there was another
component that was added
protestantism in the economical movement
acknowledging this power which
martin luther said that you have to
contend with
if you don't you're on the wrong side
yeah you will be confronted yes could it
could it affect
our people could even some within our
own church
fall back and find them not
as reprehensible as god stated in his
bible
unfortunately yes i think it could
happen
so let's have a look at the time of the
end because we want to look at the
events that are happening in the world
today
so we need some clarity and again we
have to apply the filter
and the photo is the word of god yes
daniel 11 40 and at the time of the end
shall the king of the south push at him
at whom at the king of the north right
yes
and the king of the north shall come
against him like a whirlwind
with chariots and with horsemen and with
many ships and this king of the north
shall come
against him is then the king of the
south yes
because i've also heard some people say
that that hymn
is a separate no no no he comes against
the king of the south this is the battle
between north and south
so we have to define the battle between
north and south
we have to define the king of the south
and we have to define the king of the
north
and there is a battle going on between
the two of them
and he will come against the king of the
south
with a whirlwind now whenever the bible
talks about a whirlwind
it signifies war
you can read all the parallel texts in
jeremiah we're not going to go into all
of them
but a whirlwind is coming and it's
coming out of the north
and it's babylon it's nebuchadnezzar
who's coming
and chariots and horsemen is also a
symbol of war
and with many ships and ships is a
symbol of the economy
so this will be a war that can be a
physical war
it can be a spiritual war and it
can be an economic war and it can be all
of the above
and he this is the king of the north
shall also enter into the glorious land
that's god's people now
people want to literalize this yes i
want to say this is
this is a literal battle between
northern forces and southern forces
against
israel no
we are past the type we are living in
the anti-type
what was on a local scale in the type
becomes universal in the antitype
so the king of the north in the time
of jeremiah was the king of babylon
daniel also defines this in this
prophecy and
daniel and jeremiah were
virtually contemporaries daniel actually
studied the words of jeremiah
now what is happening here so the king
of the north was the king of babylon
and the king of the south was egypt
and we have the conditions here the king
of the north will overrun the king of
the south but the king of the south will
push at
him did it happen historically yes
yes pharaoh necho came up and he tried
to overthrow
the babylonian system and the king of
the north
whacked him and he destroyed him
basically with military power
and the economy he took over
the economy of the world and he shall
enter into the countries
and shall overflow and pass over so
he will enter many countries now the
literal king of the north conquered the
then time
uh eastern countries and asia
but the anti-typical king will con
control every single country in the
world
and he will even enter the glorious land
god's people and many countries shall be
overthrown
but these shall escape out of his hand
that was an interesting
number of countries which we cannot
compare to countries today
we can only look at them you know
in an
moab and the chief children of
ammon so it's the edamites the moabites
and the ammonites
will escape now who were they
well the were the descendants
of israel yeah
so they were part and parcel of god's
family
but they'd chosen another path right
and isa intermarried with ishmaelites
correct yes so we know who they are
so in today's context we could say
that the religion of the middle east
constitutes
the moabites and the ammonites
now these were also descendants
of the abraham family
a lot so these were in a modern context
sister churches and it's interesting
that when the children of
israel were about to enter into the
promised land
it was the moabites and the ammonites
with their
short little mini dresses that entice
them
towards bell worship yes
so what are we dealing with is
we're dealing with the religious
systems and the peoples belonging to the
religious systems that are actually the
descendants of the the moabites
and the children of ammon so we're
dealing with
islam we're dealing with the sister
churches
of israel today who are they
that's protestantism and everybody who
calls himself a christian
so some of them will escape
so they're now entrapped by the king of
the north
but they will escape so those are the
children
that are in babylon yes they'll have to
come
out of babylon so it's a call
to the religious world out there
make a choice come out yeah it links on
to
revelation and the king of the north
the king of babylon yes who is the king
of babylon today it's the papacy
there can be no doubt about that verse
and he shall stretch forth his hand
also upon the countries and the land of
egypt shall not escape
so this king of the north becomes a
universal power
and his special antagonism
in this scenario is the king of the
south
now who was the king of the south was
egypt right
and uh pharaoh was the one who said who
is the lord that i should obey his voice
i do not know him i will not
obey him yes do we have people today who
say
who cares who's god i don't know who's
he why should he have anything to say in
my life i don't acknowledge him do we
have people like that yes
okay and he shall have power over the
treasures of gold
and of silver and over all the precious
things of egypt
and the libyans and the ethiopians shall
be at
his step these are fascinating verses so
we have this contest or this this
battle between two ideologies
the king of the north ideology which is
religio political
we have the king of the south which is
secular
who is the lord that i should obey him i
do not know him i don't care what he
says
i'm going to do my own thing and those
will be in apparent conflict
but the king of the north will overcome
them right yes
and the libyans and the ethiopians shall
be
at his step now
when you go back into into history
the ethiopians were also
reached by the gospel there was
the man that philip baptized remember
the eunuch and in other words the whole
world
in its religious systems will actually
be in harmony with this king of the
north
so the king of the north must have a
religion
which accommodates virtually everything
now the ethiopians who are they would
they be today
they are the symbols of africa right yes
so will there be conflicts
which introduce even
the race issue in the times that we are
living in and how does this battle
unfold verse 44
but tidings out of the east and out of
the north
shall trouble him therefore he shall go
forth with great fury to destroy and
utterly to make away many
there's one power that bothers him i
mean he's
he's in control of everything right he's
got all the countries overrun he's got
egypt uh overpowered in the end
but there's one thing that bothers him
and this is
tidings out of the east and out of the
north now what are tidings
news news it doesn't say
a mighty army out of the east or the
north it says
information information yes information
from the east and from the north now
when we think about that then we have to
ask ourselves
what could bother the king of the north
if we know who the king of the north is
it's the papacy
what should bother him now tidings out
of the east and out of the north
now the bible says that jesus christ
will be coming again right
from what direction will he be coming
from the east
aha who is this who's coming from the
east the old prophets right
so the news the tidings that something
is going to happen
from the east who brings that message
the adventists seventh the adventists
they are saying
the king will come from the east yes
and he will destroy the kingdom of
babylon
now would that upset the king of the
north yes
and why the north because he's from the
but is there higher north than he is the
true king
ah there's a true king and the throne of
god
is in the north so in other words those
who are preaching
the end time message of the coming of
christ
and worship the true god of the north
worship him who made the heavens the
earth the sea and the springs of water
they are a problem to him yes and so he
develops a great fury against them
and he wants to destroy them and remove
them off the face of the earth
so are we going to have a conflict
definitely
okay and he shall plant the tabernacle
of his palace
between the seas this is now the king
james version
in the glorious holy mountain
yet in spite of it in other words
he shall come to his end and none shall
help him
now this is rather scary when we go to
the
newer translations it looks a little bit
different
it says in the niv he will pitch his
royal tents between the seas
at the beautiful holy mountain so he's
not going in
yes yet he will come to his end and no
one will help him or the new king james
and he shall plant the tents of his
palace
between the seas and the glorious holy
mountain so it's also not in
it's between but the king james says
in what does that mean
that he will be infiltrating the church
even god's people he will be
infiltrating god's people
now does that mean that god's people
then become babylon
no but it means that there are
babylonians in god's people
amongst god's people correct does that
sort of equate with wheats and tears
and things like that yes
so we can expect i just want sorry for
interrupting
just that's your job
re-emphasize what you've just said
that that does not mean that the church
is babylon it means that there's
babylonians
in the church all right now we
can go babylonian hunting
in the church and we'll be kept very
busy
not our job no our job is to preach the
three angels message
and if we hear babylonian doctrine
within the church
our job is to expose it as babylonian
because i don't know
the one preaching babylonian doctrine is
he a babylonian
or is he influenced by the babylonians
and if he is just influenced by the
babylonians
then he can be corrected yes but if he
is a babylonian
well even then he can be converted right
correct
so our job is not to
attack certain individuals in the church
but our job is to expose error
correct and the choices that people make
as a consequence is their choice so
preach the truth let the truth
do the cutting we must not become
the ones wielding the acts so we
shouldn't be going around
saying this and this person is a
babylonian
in the church that's not our job but the
sad
news is that the king of the north will
try to destroy even god's people
and he will infiltrate them he will he
will be in the church
and i don't know who he is but my job is
to preach the truth
so let's have a look at the themes
now when it comes to this issue of the
king of the north
there's a much longer lecture that i
have given in the past perhaps you can
put a link into
the story so this slide comes from that
lecture and we're not going to deal with
all the details in that lecture we want
to see where we are in the stream of
time today
we're working towards it so please be
patient we have to set the biblical
background here
so the three themes of chapter 11
are the following there's a conflict
described
between north and south we have to find
that conflict in a modern context
yes but then there's another very
strange thing that happens there's
alliance between the north and the south
yes so although they are in conflict
there's an alliance
and there's a third point there's a
conflict with the people of god
so first there is this major conflict
between north and south
which develops into an alliance between
the north and the south
which develops into the persecution of
god's people
you know what this sounds like a
hegelian dialectic
so you have a thesis yes
and you have an antithesis
and you have a synthesis synthesis
and then you have a conflict with god's
people
verses 5 to 39 described this hegelian
sparring between the two philosophical
systems which have one collective aim
both of them the destruction of god's
people and the obliteration of true
worship
so the chapter is basically written as a
marism
now marism is when you are
contrasting opposites heaven and earth
that's amerism north and south
they seem to be diametrically opposed
but amerism takes the two extremes
and incorporates everything in between
okay
so in other words the whole system
has one final aim the destruction of
god's people
and the destruction of the truth that's
the aim
of the story so now we have to analyze
it
there's a fascinating verse
in daniel 11 verse 27
and both these kings that's the king of
the north and the king of the south so
that's the religio political system
and the secular political system
the one saying god must be involved and
the other one's saying who's god i'm not
interested in god
yes and both of these
two mindsets as it were
will do mischief and shall speak
lies at one table
what does that sound it sounds like a
conspiracy that's a that's a terrible
word
but it shall not prosper for yet the end
shall be at the time appointed so in
other words even though these two will
form a synthesis
speak lies both of them be mischievous
and actually be sitting at one table
although they appear to be opposites
even willing to kill each other
now which organization in the world
has a philosophy which says that
they will choose opposite sides of an
issue
even to the point of death in order that
mother church
may be the victim which organization has
that philosophy
the society of jesus the jesuits the
jesuits
absolutely so
what are the actions of the king of the
north
daniel 11 32 and such as do
wickedly against the covenant
covenant is the two commandments the
commandments god's word
the bible that's the covenant right
between man and god the whole package
and such as do wickedly against the
covenant
shall he corrupt with flatteries but the
people that do know their god shall be
strong
and do exploits in other words they will
work even under those conditions
and they that understand amongst the
people shall instruct
many yet they shall fall by the sword
and by flame
by captivity by spoil many days
that's the sad history of the christian
church
so we are constantly being rubbed up but
this will
reach a climax at the end and the
conflict is
against god's people yes
now this little slide
is quite fascinating noah was a
conspiracy
theorist and then it started to rain
i find it interesting that whenever you
speak about
prophecy in the context of the time that
we are living in
there are these voices that go up that
shout
conspiracy theory
now is it a conspiracy theory when the
bible actually
says that they're conspiring and sitting
at one table and talking or is it just a
biblical fact
it's a biblical fact i was sitting and
wondering a while back
the words conspiracy theory if it wasn't
also thought up by the jesuits
too because there is talk that it was
the jesuit some
say it was the secret service of the
united states
with regard to the kennedy issue because
as soon as you have those words this
the emphasis of what's being said is
they're watered down immediately
yeah it's downplayed what is the
opposite of a conspiracy
theorist well there's a nice phrase that
they've coined
the opposite would be a coincidence
apologist
or a coincidence theorist in other words
there is no conspiracy there is no plan
everything happens just by coincidence
it just so happens
there is no enemy of god we are
misinterpreting the bible the papacy
is not a problem the little horn is not
rome
none of these issues are important so if
you are not a conspiracy theorist
in regards to biblical prophecy you
become
a coincidence apologist then you might
as well throw the bible away
you might as well not study prophecy
because everything is hype hazard what's
the point of predicting the future
if everything's going to be a
coincidence so
to our coincidence apologists amongst us
i would say study your bibles and become
conspiracy theorists
in a prophetic sense not in a wild sense
of anything goes and every nonsense
is acceptable apply the falter yes
which is the word of god and this is
what we will try and do
in this little talk
verse 36 and the king shall do according
to his will
and he shall exalt himself and magnify
himself above
every god doesn't paul speak with a
similar voice
in thessalonians when he talks about
this king that will set
himself up in the temple of god in the
church of god
saying that he is god same language
so this king this king of the north and
he shall exalt himself
and magnify himself above every god
we've looked at that in the doctrine of
the serpent
and shall speak marvelous things against
the god of gods
i know the bible says it but we don't
teach that we teach what the serpent
taught
amazing and then the sad words he shall
prosper
till the indignation be accomplished
for that is determined shall be done he
will come to his
end yes and anybody who's associated
with him
will come to their end too the only
solution is to separate yourself from
the system neither shall he regard the
god of his fathers
nor the desire of women nor regard
any god for he shall magnify himself
above them all
so he will not regard the god of his
fathers
he says he's a christian organization
but he doesn't do what god says he does
what the serpent says
yes he will not
regard the desire of women now women
of course is a reference to churches in
the bible a woman is a church
and the desire of the churches of the
world is jesus
jesus christ the desire of ages
so he will not regard the god of the
bible
and he will minimize jesus christ there
is no atonement
why did jesus die an act of futility
is no different to us we also die right
and he shall magnify himself above all
he is the way to salvation
not jesus christ come to me and i will
give you rest
not jesus don't go to him or come to
mary or whatever but just don't go to
jesus
but in his estate shall he honor the god
of forces
now the god of forces was the god of war
the god
of nimrod that was
the god of war it was lucifer mars
and a god whom his fathers knew not
shall he honor with gold and silver and
precious stones and pleasant things
just walk into a cathedral and you'll
see this
and thus shall he do in the most
strongholds with a strange god
it is such a sad statement
that even though he worships the
doctrine of the serpent
and acknowledges his authority
is so successful with this strange god
yes
whom we shall acknowledge and increase
with glory and shall cause them to rule
over many and shall
divide the land for gain
who divided up this world into its
little quarters
wasn't that wrong didn't he say
my dear child portugal i will draw a
line
through south america and this portion
will give to you
brazil and this portion over here will
give to
my dear child of spain and so
the world is divided up and the maps are
drawn
it's wrong where these decisions were
made
so in summary both the kings of the
north and the south
are enemies of god they have one name
the destruction of god's people
so we must conclude that both must be
under the control
of the archdeceiver
but they're fighting each other
employing a
galleon dialectic to induce a collective
mindset
conducive to his schemes so we have
thesis antithesis
a massive clash yes huge destruction
and the end thereof is a synthesis
which then is directed against god's
people correct
and you mean meaning the god's people
the commanding people
absolutely so typologically the king of
the north must represent the religious
political alliance that would attempt to
force god's people to worship according
to its dictates
as babylon tried to force the hebrews to
worship according to
its dictates and you can read the rest
of daniel where they had to bow down to
the image and they refused they were
thrown into the furnace in other words
persecution if you don't go along with
their
religious way of thinking yes and it
must be church and state
combined so the king of the south
which is geographically egypt enslaved
the people of god
that's interesting they refuse to
acknowledge jave
all the right of the hebrews to worship
him according to their conscience
but they did not force them to worship
the egyptian deities
so what do we have here so we have
secularism
yes secularism which says
don't care about jave and you can do
whatever you like
but you will not
worship according to your way you will
be
slaves and pharaoh said
you shall not shabbat you shall not rest
on the seventh day
that's what he said you shall not
shabbat you shall work on that day.
so the motives of the king of the south
were the
secular whereas the motives of the king
of the north were
religious now which one is going to
eventually win out
the king of the north the king of the
north
now that we've given the the biblical
background
in other words we have applied the
filter so that we cannot be accused of
being conspiracy theorists
then we will look at the signs of the
end
and then we will tie it into the events
that are happening in the world today
to see if the filter is giving us
a correct analysis of what is happening
so let's just recap some of the things
that will happen at the end
remember jesus was sitting on the mount
of olives and they came to him and they
wanted to know the signs
of his coming and of the end of the
world yes
and he answered them and he said take
heed that no man deceive you
deception was going to be the one thing
now didn't these two kings sit at one
table
yes and told lies yes what is that
deception deception for many shall come
in my name
saying i am christ and shall deceive
many
in other words they will take the
emphasis away from the real coming of
christ and put something else in its
place
and you shall hear of wars and rumors of
wars
now the king of the north did he come
with
chariots and horses yes
and a whirlwind which are all symbols of
war right yes
and we're dealing with the end now
see that you be not troubled for all
these things much come to pass but the
end is not yet what must
take place the synthesis yes and then
the conflict with god's people
now what will be the components nation
shall rise against nation now if you
look that up
it will say aetnos against atmos
and if you look up in the strong's
concordance it will
say one of the issues will be race
there will be racial tension can we
expect racial tension at the end
definitely how do we deal with it right
kingdom against kingdom now you're
dealing with political entities
so we'll have political entities
fighting against each other
we'll have racial issues fighting
against each other
there will be famines and pestilences
and earthquakes besides all this you
have all the natural
disasters so we will have
covet 19s and earthquakes and all of
those
issues but
nation against nation kingdom against
kingdom
now in the context of a battle between
north and south a real battle
which is actually being decided at one
table
and people are being fed lies so now
here's my question
whose side do i choose do i
choose the side of the king of the north
because at least he's making religious
noises
and it sounds biblical and moral and
correct
or do i choose the side of secularism
and say you know what they have a point
church and state should be totally
separate that there's some bad and the
other
and which side do i choose when it comes
to racial tension
which side do i choose when it comes to
dealing
with pestilences and how to deal with
all of those
isn't it the king of the north and the
king of the south
doing both of these things and all of
these things sitting at one table
sitting at one table so you don't choose
a side
you cannot choose a side
all these are the beginning of sorrows
and once this conflict
has brought about synthesis
then they shall deliver you up to be
afflicted and they shall kill you and
those you shall be hated
of how many nations all nations all
nations for my name's sake
once they reach synthesis
god's people will be a thorn in their
flesh
we have to look at this yes and now we
will go
into the situations that we have in the
world today
and we'll ask ourselves how far
down the line are we where are we
in the stream of time yes this is a good
background
information set that you've just given
us
i hope so so that when we look at
everything that's happening and even not
even the ones that we're going to show
if you continue to watch what's
happening around
then you have the filter of how to look
at these things
and then you cannot be a conspiracist
because the
filter is the word of god yes and the
word of god tells us which way
the wind is going to blow yes and who
the the role players are going to be
and you can the whole time get an
eagle's view of this whole situation and
not become
part of one of the sides so you actually
an observer and you know that all of
these systems will eventually be in the
pocket called babylon yes
because the king of the north is going
to control it all right yes
and therefore you cannot choose any of
these sides
you have to say to the people when
you're going into that particular
direction this is where it's heading
when you're going into that particular
direction which looks
exactly the opposite like north versus
south and it doesn't matter how
correct it looks to you you must know
through what you've just
seen now stand back and look at this
thing
what's going on and you must recognize
them both as being part of the
babylonian system
and what is the message come out get
them out of there
come out of that come out of that in
other words don't take part in that
don't take part in that do not take part
in this
even though you think that wow this is a
wonderful thing
yes you're being lied to yes you're
being deceived
it doesn't matter how morally correct it
seems there's only one way
separate yourselves from all of these
systems
it says further then shall many be
offended and shall betray one another
and shall hate one another
now that's a very sad statement because
that's going to happen across the board
there will be betrayals on every front
even within our own
ranks yes many false prophets shall
arise
they shall deceive many in other words
the
preachers and the churches will be
preaching and
babylonian power will be
brought to bear on this situation
iniquity shall abound we know that
iniquity
is abounding in the world today
the love of many shall wax cold and he
that shall endure unto the end the same
shall be saved
and the gospel of the kingdom shall be
preached in
all the world for a witness unto
all nations and then shall
the end come now there are people that
are saying
oh the end cannot be yet because all of
these nations must be reached
aren't they all watching the events of
the world
aren't they all tuned in don't they get
the exact same news that we get
worldwide now the gospel of the
the truth of the kingdom those who have
a covenant with god
when this message becomes prominent as
opposed to what
the rest is preaching will the nations
not see it on the news
will they not be seeing that there is a
witness
and all nations will see it so we do not
have
to have millions of years or thousands
or
exactly and at that time shall michael
stand up the great prince which stands
for the children of thy people and there
shall be a time of trouble
such as never was since there was a
nation
even to that time and at that time thy
people shall be delivered
every one that shall be found written in
the book
what can we expect a time of trouble
such as the world has never seen
uh does that include the first and the
second world war
yes can it be worse than that it's going
to be it's going to be worse
what about everything what about the the
black plague
yes it's going to be worse than that so
we're going to have pestilences we're
going to have
earthquakes we're going to have
wars we're going to have a time of
trouble amongst
nations and peoples internally
externally kingdom against kingdom we're
going to have
trouble such as you cannot believe
but god's people will then be delivered
matthew 24 22 and accept those days be
shortened
there should no flesh be saved i know
that refers to the 1260 day period
but also to the time of the end
for the elect's sake the days will be
shortened
the last events will be rapid ones
here's an interesting quote from the
great controversy
to set the tone for our
discussion on the historic events that
are taking
place right now but as the church
approaches her final deliverance
satan needs to work with greater power
he comes down having great
wrath because he knows that he has but a
short time
revelation 12 12 he will work with all
power and signs and lying
wonders for 6 000 years
that mastermind that once was highest
amongst the angels of god
has been wholly bent to the work of
deception
and run so the king of the north king of
the south conflict is also a deception
they're both under his control right yes
so he feels
absolutely nothing for
even destroying his own people
if the end product can just benefit his
cause
yes the end justifies the means
whose statement is that
isn't that the statement of the jesuits
exactly
and all the depth of satanic skill and
subtlety acquired
all the cruelty developed during these
struggles of the ages will be brought to
bear against
god's people in the final conflict is
this in harmony with daniel 11
yes absolutely
and in this time of peril
the followers of christ are to bear to
the world the warning of the lord's
second advent the tidings from the east
and the people are to be prepared to
stand
before him at his coming without spot
and blameless they need the
righteousness of christ
this is amazing this is beautiful yes
so not the religion of cain not the
religion of the serpent the religion of
the bible
at this time the special endowment of
divine grace and power is not
less needful to the church than in
apostolic days this is the loud cry
this is the latter rain in a time
of peril now we're sitting under
lockdown at the moment
but this lockdown
is constantly on the move it is growing
and there are tensions developing in the
world that we need to look at
the days in which we live are solemn and
important the spirit of god is gradually
but surely being withdrawn drawn from
the earth
plagues and judgments already falling
upon the despisers of the grace of god
there will be calamities by sea
unsettled state of society do we see
that
oh definitely alarms of war
are potentious
we must look at that they forecast
approaching events of the greatest
magnitude can we expect war differently
the agencies of evil are combining their
forces
and consolidating so first we have to
have this conflict between north and
south
which is planned which will be
with destruction unbelievable
destruction
planned at one table lying to the world
they are strengthening for the last
great crisis
great changes are soon to take place in
our world
and the final movements will be rapid
ones
this is where we are in the stream of
time and
shall we look at it yes is it a
conspiracy theory
if you put it through the bible and it
fits no
no as a conspiracy theorist then it
started to rain
so if we say the conspiracy theory which
we are
proposing is that there will be
a time of trouble such as never was and
that
in the midst of this time of trouble the
message must go out
that christ is coming again and that we
need to be covered by his
righteousness in other words
he was the one who said i have not come
to abolish the law but to fulfill it
god's people must go back to god's
commandments and not
the world's commandments so we're not
talking conspiracy theories
we're talking biblical prophecies
and you shall hear of wars and rumors of
wars
see that you are not troubled for all
these things must come to pass but the
end is not yet
the persecution must all come right
the time is near when large cities will
be swept away
now people will say you are
fear-mongering
am i fear-mongering or is the bible
warning us of these things
the bible is warning us so do we need to
bring across the urgency of the matter
and if we show in history as it unfolds
that these things are happening
isn't that doing our duty great
so we must beware not to be coincidence
apologists
and all should be warned of these coming
judgments
it's our duty oh that god's people had a
sense of the impending destruction of
thousands of
cities now almost given to idolatry
that's not talking about the first world
war
that's not talking about the second
world war there were
cities that were destroyed in that war
but it wasn't
thousands of cities how can thousands of
cities be destroyed
by natural disasters but what about
war isn't it
big war a view of the great destruction
last friday morning just before i awoke
a very impressive scene was presented
before
me i seemed to awake from sleep
but was not in my home from the windows
i could behold a terrible confrontation
great balls of fire were falling upon
our
houses upon houses and from these balls
fiery arrows were flying in every
direction
it was impossible to check the fires
that were kindled
and many places were being destroyed the
terror of the people was
indescribable i think we can expect fire
from heaven
what do you think yes so what could make
great balls of fire go in every
direction
explosions right now this was written in
a time
when there were no airplanes yet flying
around there were no bombers
there were no bombs or or rockets that
could come
bearing down on a city this is the
description of a modern war
yes of a modern situation could be
natural
like a meteor shower or something
could also be fake but this sounds very
real indeed
so let us have a look at the possibility
that we are on the verge of these events
because that would tell us where we are
look what's happening in the world let's
look at the signs
and see if what we've just gone through
is applicable is there talk of war
let's have a look at a few newspaper
reports
they express this comes from may 28
2020.
world war iii fears erupt
of the satellite footage shows 5 000
chinese
troops mobilized for conflict
fears of all-out global war have been
raised this week after
shocking satellite footage revealed that
china was mobilizing its armed forces
with
more than 5 000 troops ready for combat
this was talking about the conflict
between china and
india and they've been
quite harsh there even killing each
other
with barbed wire poles yes and
rather gruesome here's another article
from june 2020 world war three
mapped the six places where world war
three
could break out in 2020
world war three fears were ignited
across the globe just a few days into
2020 and now they have been sparked
again
but which five places around the globe
are the most
likely to be starting points for world
war
iii so they mentioned the us and iran
iran and israel us and turkey
kashmir u.s north korea
u.s and china it's interesting that
the nuclear facilities in iran
have recently had serious fires and
there was talk of
maybe it was sabotage maybe it was
a movement by israel or whatever
but the the big conflict seems to be
developing
in the south china sea yes
yes the express says world war iii alert
as expert
reveals most dangerous threat to the
united states and china
china u.s rivalry in the south china sea
is
escalating due to the buildup of naval
maneuvers where vessels from
both sides are sailing dangerously close
to each other
increasing the risk of military clash
so there are tensions developing in the
world strong tensions
is this just cyber rattling or is there
something more associated with us
here's the republic world.com china
warns
us against intermediate-range missile
deployment
at japan's military base
so the conflict is not just between the
us and china
japan is involved india is involved
the philippines are involved there are
many nations that are involved taiwan
is a very central part of this
hong kong riots
wu said that if the united states
insists on deploying missiles at its
military base in japan
it will be provoking china to take
necessary
measures to resolutely fight back
he also suggested japan and other
relevant countries proceed
cautiously from the perspective of
regional peace and stability
and not fall victim to the geopolitical
plot
of the united states meanwhile the u.s
has been challenging
beijing's claims on the south china sea
and helping taiwan militarily to boost
its defense inventory
and last month taiwan revealed that it
is planning to buy harpoon anti-ship
missiles from the united states
so there's an escalation taking place
there
now the king of the north
and the king of the south china
what kind of government is that secular
it's a secular government communist god
is out of it
so is this king of the south or king of
the north so that's king of the son
donald trump who put him in position
according to him
god put him in that position his party
says that he's
chosen by god right so who's he
representing
king of the north king of the north and
the king of the north as we know is
babylon
so that's the papacy sitting behind
there do we have jesuits working on that
side
yes do we have jesuits working on the
other side
yes they didn't didn't
tamborini the jesuit general say that
from this window i control not only
europe
but china and didn't the papacy
recently praise china for its
social doctrine so are they playing both
sides of the story
sitting at one table you think so
interesting japan
could carry the day in a u.s china
conflict
so is japan becoming involved as the us
ramps up covet 19 inspired threats
against china
and fears of a possible armed kin
conflict
mount many strategic analysts have
speculated that the
asia pacific strategic balance
may have shifted in favor of china
in sight of its fast rising military
might and capabilities
new spending will also go towards
deploying japan's
first real aircraft carriers since world
war
ii actually they're not even allowed to
build these things right
under the treaty they're not allowed to
do it but they're doing it
as well as enhancing its space security
i find that interesting including
through research
into using electronic waves to disrupt
what the budget terms
enemy communication systems
likely meaning china's some observers
believe that the japanese navy
is now as capable and possibly superior
to any force in the pacific including
china
so this is happening behind the scenes
quietly while nobody noticed
the world is engulfed in the pandemic at
this stage
while this is happening while this is
happening and japan
is preparing for a military conflict
japan is building aircraft carriers
china's thinking about thinking them
is this conflict definitely
now japan is an ally of the united
states
and they've got an agreement as well
that we'll see that
if the one if japan for instance if any
country attacks attacks them it's the
u.s is obliged
to help so uh they are in alliance with
the king of the north right
so the japanese navy's first aircraft
carrier in 75 years is almost ready to
deploy why are they building these
things all of a sudden
are they just little deterrents or are
they planning
something the chinese military has
already considered how it might sink the
japanese carriers
this comes from forbes june 26 2020
of course the japanese fleet is hardly
defenseless
japan deploys more destroyers equipped
with the latest
aegis air defense system than any other
country
except the united states and those two
are together
and they're together in this so
yeah you can see the the ships
that are sailing the south china sea
why this japan china island dispute
could be asia's next military flashpoint
so there's a lot of military exercise
going on
and china is taking one
island after the other don't they know
that that would lead to conflict
they have an agreement that they would
not do it
yes they still do it so that's latency
so are they sitting at one table and
planning this and telling us a different
story
is it possible according to the
scripture or are we now in conspiracy
theories
so for the first time in six years
two u.s navy aircraft carriers
are in the south china sea
the latest show of military might from
washington
as it pushes back against china's sweeky
sweeping claim to much of the contested
region
now i find it interesting that china
did some cyber rattling and said we can
destroy those
aircraft carriers because we have the
missiles to do it
and the united states ignored them
and sailed right through with the nimitz
and
the ronald reagan so
there is a show of force definitely
now you have a little video that
tells us a little bit more as to what is
happening
about these wars and rumors of wars
cnn report a cnn report let's have a
look
what it is calling a success in
containing the novel coronavirus
outbreak
china is now shifting its focus to
military preparedness
making what some u.s military experts
perceive to be
power moves on multiple fronts
china is flexing its military muscle
trialling its new aircraft carrier at
sea a few weeks ago
and last year parading some of its
latest missile technology through
beijing
president xi jinping addressed china's
national people's congress last month
saying china should comprehensively
strengthen the training of troops
and combat preparedness in recent weeks
chinese troops were sent to china's
border with india the two countries
disputing territorial claims
government-controlled media releasing
these images of china's military
inaction
and last year chinese paramilitary
troops mobilizing to the border with
hong kong
but among the areas most concerning for
the u.s and its allies
the south china sea china claims these
waters as sovereign territory within a
designated boundary
which an international tribunal has
dismissed as without legal basis
nevertheless
china's built up its naval presence here
it's constructed
islands where recent satellite images
appear to show
more permanent military bases some
southeast asian nations have alleged
china has even harassed foreign vessels
carrying out oil exploration and fishing
to counter the chinese claims the u.s
navy has conducted multiple
freedom of navigation exercises in the
sea in recent months
as well as sailing through the taiwan
strait shithun
says those exercises show it is the u.s
provoking china wu suggests that while
china has no desire for conflict
the chinese will protect its sovereignty
at all cost
china has also unlawfully claimed
territory in the pacific ocean
threatening freedom of navigation and
international trade
experts are now calling for a channel
for negotiations to ease the tensions
between the two sides
but that seems increasingly unlikely a
complete severing could set the two
world powers
on a collision course at sea
so that was an interesting little
summary by cnn
and uh by the way whose side are they on
cnn yes king of the south king of the
south
it's uh we must start understanding this
is how you
should look at everything yes india
china skirmish
in galwan prompts fears of conflict
report
so this one has escalated to the loss of
human life already
yes and now and they're talking about
two nuclear powers here that are
ready to strike at each other then of
course
there's also the conflict between india
and pakistan about kashmir
so there are lots of areas here where
there is potential
for rumors of war yes
and then you have this massive parade
with this comes from deutsche wertchafts
which means german economic news
where it says that the russians held the
greatest
military parade ever since
their victory over germany so the
russians are
showing their military strength all over
the world
the usa and turkey are starting to
talk about creating a
unity area in kurdistan
so that will create further conflicts
with
russia for example who stands on the
other side of this
issue and then this fascinating story
about space war japan
becomes the latest country that's
preparing to fight
world war iii in space
now donald trump started the space force
as you well know
japanese prime minister shinzo abe has
announced
plans to form a defense unit designed to
wage
war in space the space
the main mission unit will launch in
april
as part of japan's air self defense
force
so whatever technology they're going to
use there
that is fascinating a number of nations
are now developing space weapons with
concerns growing
that china and russia are seeking ways
to interfere
and disable or destroy spacecraft
so there is a
mass of information out there regarding
a coming conflict here's the metro and
it says the uk
needs to build a space force to get
ready to fight terrorists and wage
war in the heavens i find this
interesting you know if you really want
to become a conspiracist
you could say are they even planning to
war against christ when he is coming
but let us not go there
industry leaders have warned in the
future
terrorists and nation states will be
able to wreak economic
havoc by targeting communication
satellites
the incoming president of the uk space
will whitehorn has said we will see
and should see the creation of a space
force in the uk to help protect the
nation against
these threats we are about to go
through an industrial revolution in
space
it's interesting that the world
is preparing for a space war
and we are preaching an invasion
from outside of this world
that will put an end to this world's
kingdoms
so does russia have a space force well
let's have a look
ross cosmos is a state corporation that
was established in august 2015 to
oversee and implement a comprehensive
reform
of the russian space industry so we're
all going into
preparing for a space wall
op ed india needs its own space force
so all the nations are suddenly jumping
onto this bandwagon
india is setting up a military space
agency called the defense space
agency that's expected to command of
all the space assets of the india's navy
navy and air force the idea of dsa was
muted a few years back possibly with a
view to make an
incremental increase in the
space-related defense
infrastructure the united states of
course with its space
force interesting logo that they have
over there
so the mission is a military service
that organizes trains and equips space
forces in order to protect u.s and
allied
interests in space and to provide space
capabilities
to the joint force so japan
and the united states are allies
and they've got their own and they have
their own so are they
talks about wars and rumors of wars
not even only on earth now it's in space
as well
even in space china wants to dominate
space and the us
must take countermeasures defense news
and we can see that all of this is very
recent
like you just like you said earlier
[Music]
september last year trump gave the
go-ahead for the space force and i think
it was something like 15 billion
dollars that's allocated to setting up
the space force i think
they've even got a series well a
spoof series going on about it on
netflix
absolutely so the world is being
prepared
and netflix of course is jesuit theater
to prepare the mindset of the people for
what is coming
and we're not promoting anybody watching
it but it's interesting that one of the
creators of this is also was great of
simpsons oh that's very interesting
well i'm glad we've got the finger on
the pulse there
so china is preparing for its next
launch
and it's scheduled for this month right
so there are interesting things
happening
now i found it interesting i read that
australia
is wanting to introduce longer-range
missiles because they see
china as a threat from the north and for
the first time
they used the words rogue nation
and they were referring to the situation
in the time
of adolf hitler with the rise of
the nazi regime in europe
and they said you know the steps that
were taken
were so late and that's why it was such
a major conflict
the world should have been proactive and
so
they're talking about china as this next
rogue nation
now just to sum up yes we said
that there is a war between
north and south between one mindset and
another mindset
question do we have
a war unfolding
within the borders of the united states
of america
where you have this communist
mindset being in juxtaposition
with the evangelical religious mindset
do we have that war
developing in the united states is it
acrimonious
yes it is at a very touching point it's
at flash point
right so we have this clash between
north philosophy and south philosophy
within the nations
and the united states is just symbolic
of the other nations as well
we have the same clash in every nation
definitely
in europe in africa the same mindset
clashes
is taking place good so we have it in
every nation the north-south conflict
do we have it on a national level on a
kingdom against kingdom level
yes yes we've just seen this we've seen
japan
we've seen australia we've seen india
we've seen china seen the united states
we've seen the uk we've seen russia
they're all preparing for a conflict
they're building up towards the conflict
rogue state what philosophy must be
overrun
the secular the king of the south
philosophy the south king of the south
philosophy
mindset must be overrun it is
so powerfully entrenched in communism
in china at the moment that
it will take a major event
to break that power yes now
we we've applied the filter we've looked
at the situation
we can see we're sitting on a powder keg
how many cities will be destroyed
thousands thousands are we
on the verge of a great conflict
on this planet now i'm not saying it
will happen
but i'm saying it's pretty biblical that
it should happen and
we will see where this leads to i think
we must discuss the other issues
of what will be the synthesis
how will it come about that there will
be a synthesis at the end of this great
conflict
between the king of the north and the
king of the south
so that we can get to the point where
the final target
yes can be addressed which is god's
people commandment keeping people
so i think we'll discuss that in another
episode
yes it was a nice discussion
until next time let's have a word of
prayer pray for us our heavenly father
thank you so much
for giving us such information through
your word
and through the spirit of prophecy that
we can look at the world
and see the things happening and put it
through the filter that you've provided
we ask that you bless us until we meet
again
in jesus name amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you